congratulations on this film it's a good
seems to be incredibly a someone and
everyone keeps talking about how much
trust Trust trust there was that you
asked people to have in you but when you
went home at night did you think oh my
gosh all these people are trusting me
this is such a big undertaking no only
because I worked so hard in preparation
I actually went to bed very tired and
exhausted and but exuberant that I was
going to get up the next day and that's
the best way to go to bed you know to
put in a hard day's work yeah I was I
was just prepared there was never a
moment of debt you were just thinking
I've got that there was tons of debt
while I was preparing tons I'll time
some fear and terrifying I shouldn't do
this I can't what am i stupid am I crazy
but then once I got on set that first
day I felt very confident and how much
was that trust a big part for you and
being able to release the character it
was everything you know when when you
can trust your director and also you
know trust your you know your co-star
you're the leading actor in the film
that it just provides for the ability to
me for me to be vulnerable in ways that
you know I might not be vulnerable in my
everyday life you know Ali's not me and
he wanted me to play this role and I
wanted it to be as authentic as possible
and I wanted to give it all over to him
I'll never forget when he was checking
to make sure that if there was makeup on
my face with a makeup wipe you know and
if there was something there he'd be
like take it off I want to see her face
and you know it was it was a beautiful
experience he's he's a tremendous
director I can't say enough wonderful
things about him and we had an instant
instant chemistry when he first met and
you know the friendship just grew from
there and I had I had the utmost faith
in him that he would just soar soar
making this film and I think everyone
could feel it when we watch it which
makes it that much more beautiful on the
other side when you're watching
something like that how much of you was
in Ally would you say well you know in
some ways I'm nothing like Ally because
she completely gave up on herself and
she gave up on her dream and I didn't do
that
you know I hit the ground running when I
was 19 and was like I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna bang on every door and I'm
gonna drag my piano around New York and
sing everywhere that I can and I even
did you know Club tours four years after
I was signed three shows a night you
know but at the same time you know all
of me is an ally
you know I pulled from everything in my
life from my past from current
situations uh you know every everything
that I have you know in my emotional
Arsenal and in my heart and in my mind I
wanted to give to him every day on set
so that he had all of me and I I'm just
very grateful that I you know had a
friend you know because even in scenes
when I was supposed to be mad at him you
know or hurt by him I still felt you
know the trust and safe and he's just an
incredible director